mesdames et messieurs les députés
insoumis vous m'avez insulté 15 jours
vous sortez mais vous m'avez insulté
personne n'a craqué personne n'a craqué
et nous sommes là devant vous pour la
réforme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
a permis de lever tous les liens sur les
femmes sur les villes sur l'ensemble des
sujets sur lesquels vous avez cherché à
tromper les princesses et les Français
mais personne ne s'y tromper et nous
nous donnons rendez-vous effectivement
le 5 mars prochain dans les rues de
France et en toutes les entreprises de
France où nous allons effectivement
mettre à l'arrêt le pays je vous
remercie je voudrais d'abord remercier
mes collègues parce que nous avons
travaillé nous avons travaillé durant
des nombreuses semaines parce qu'une
réforme des retraites demande beaucoup
de technicité et ce dont nous venons
nous rendre compte c'est qu'au fond vous
n'aviez pas travaillé vous n'avez pas
travaillé sur cette réforme vous n'avez
vous avez ressorti les mêmes amendements
que lors du PLFSS il n'y a pas de
travail de fond au moins le
rassemblement national qui n'a déposé
que finalement que très peu
d'amendements reconnaît et des idées de
ne pas travailler dessus et au moins n'a
pas bloqué comme vous l'avez fait bloqué
la discussion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le règlement de la part de Monsieur
Lucas puis monsieur bottorel qui madame
Daloz pour un rappel aux règlements
rappelle au règlement 70 à Liné à deux
mises en cause personnelle rappellent
règlement au titre de l'article 100 de
notre règlement nous avons convenu avec
tous les présidents de groupe que à
partir de maintenant nous tenterions de
rester sur les amendements et que nous
arrêtions les rappels au règlement assez
simple non mais alors si ce que l'on
convient entre les présidents de groupe
ne tient pas trois secondes je ne vois
pas comment nous allons faire
fonctionner cette assemblée les 20000
amendements déposés par la nuprez auront
empêché notre assemblée d'achever
l'examen du texte au terme de 9 jours de
séance et 73 heures de débat
le gouvernement ne peut pas prolonger
l'examen du texte sans réduire le temps
que le Sénat doit avoir
l'Assemblée nationale n'ayant pas émis
de vote en première lecture sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi le
gouvernement on saisira le texte le
Sénat du test il a initialement présenté
modifié par les amendements votés par
votre assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]